ces modèles j'avais de l'eau tout
simplement merci beaucoup pour tout ce
qu'il a fait pour moi
il a mis sa santé en danger pour moi et
je suis reconnaissant pour ce à quoi je
pense à ça j'y revenais pas dormir
fermer le jeu la seule chose que je peux
faire pour nous c'est l'effet du bon
travail pour le tiendrait sûreté
d'examen oui j'ai réduit un combat il
n'est jamais gagnée tant que deux
derniers rounds de napa soleil dont qui
ont vu réussissait on va dire c'est le
premier c'est le premier jour du reste
de ta vie mon gamin me bats à l'heure
actuelle pour que ce gamin restent en
france et des papiers français qu'est en
train de faire une grève de la faim
depuis le 3 janvier
ma vie je pensais pas à la rencontre
quelqu'un aussi bon pour ce qu'il a fait
pour moi vous faut toujours quelqu'un
pour quelqu'un cette fois ci c'est moi
après tu feras paris pour quelqu'un et
puis voilà
[Musique]
je suis content de retrouver mon poste
de commencer à travailler
ça a déjà reçu fait tellement content dé
tous mes amis et ma famille me manquait
depuis que je suis venu en france j'ai
jamais été aussi content comme ça
quant aux autres ce que j'irais sans
ordi de commencer mon travail
oui
part aux médias par rapport à tout ce
qui s'est passé sur internet le
mouvement en fête a pris d'ampleur est
devenu international enfin après on a vu
sa bouille par toi tout confié un piola
nous on a reçu les demandes de mariages
tout est forcément ça fait plaisir non
mais on sent présenter ça fait super
plaisir c'est qu'on vous on n'aurait
jamais dû coller de ce à quoi en fait
c'est vrai c'est nous on est des cercles
boulant clé un gamin on aurait dû
reverser la table comme ça c'est pas
possible
enfin c'est pas notre rôle premièrement
et puis serait dû être réfléchis bien
avant fins et c'est pas à moi de faire
réfléchir les grand festin
malheureusement j'ai dû le faire eh eh
ben on l'a fait on a réussi donc c'est
cool mauvaise
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
sa soirée les personnalités ou via le
quidam cerveau pareil et ils ont su se
lever quand il fallait et donc on leur
enlève remerciera jamais en fait on
n'aura pas assez d'une vie pour l'acier
et
[Musique]
c'est grâce à lui que le grand y ait là
quoi ce matin j'aime beaucoup les
remercier pour tout ce qu'ils ont fait
tout ce qu'ils ont fait pour moi c'est
je m'attendais pas à ça de leur part
comme ça que j'ai gagné
on peut doit gagner tous ensemble parce
qu'on soit là mener le combat tous
ensemble gilbert et merci beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup aux enfants de choeur
il est loin d'être fini on va travailler
sur un texte de loi qui puissiez
protéger ou une ordonnance qui puissent
les protéger jusqu'à obtention d'un
diplôme ou nuls ou d'un cursus craig
quel que soit leur âge
donc je pense que ça c'est une logique
hisser en rond on continue la logique en
fait on ne manque de rien plus rien de
plus c'est que que la logique soit
respectée
[Musique]